oh let's start a slow clap for January
good job January you're back yeah
putting us through this let's talk about
it don't think you don't say Oh watch it
look bye Parma watch this revered I'll
be fine but nothing of it so the by by
man is admittedly an interesting premise
about this spirit called the by by man
if you say his name he'll come after you
if other people learn his name and then
say his name he'll come after them too
he kind of spreads like a virus but if
no one knows or says his name's - dad's
no power and he's just nowhere what this
movie actually is is a movie that
unfolds that premise at a snail's pace
let's look was Chet ever with the worst
acting you can imagine for theatrical
release any way outside of porn trying
to think of silver linings somewhere in
this movie like something that was nice
like I said it's just kind of the
premise itself actually there are
flashbacks to his story the story
actually starts out in 1969 it's really
brief I was like that is the interesting
story I would have liked who stayed
there and it's like this movie was
thought up as a story that was supposed
to take place in 1969 they were like we
don't have the budget for that we're
gonna have to make it take place in
modern day you know budget good actors
though right did you hear me say budget
you mean it - for the first half of this
movie I was like nothing is happening
when I'm in a horror movie and I'm
praying for a jump cut just to pick up
the pace somehow you know there's bad
news everyone
I hate jump cuts I can't stand him in
horror movies the thing I hate is a
boring ass movie so I did it where our
way we're between a rock and a hard
place here now this is just dumpster
fire garbage the awkward thing for me is
I haven't run into this situation before
I was at a screening it's in Los Angeles
the director and producers were there at
the screening they came outside if he
wears like alright everyone hi enjoy you
look like the perfect audience of enjoy
our garbage any kind of human nice and I
was like oh man these guys poured their
heart and soul into this I'm sure you're
sweet people and I'm sorry you poured
your heart and soul into this that said
you shoved [ __ ] down my throat that you
made me eat sand I got to talk about it
from the opening shot alone this dude
pulls up in his car and then the camera
follows him and I was like this looks
like a student film and this movie just
the set up is set up cliche like the
main dudes brother when he comes I was
like hey little brother how's it going
Oh mom said to pick up this and that I'm
like okay first of all you say hey
little brother it's just the movie going
hey brothers when you could have just
had him pull up and be like oh hey by
the way mom said to do this and that and
then the audience would just assess that
hey they're brothers you don't need to
make it so on the nose
best friends a walking cliche the main
actress Oh
the audience would literally laugh at
what she said what you said it like
she's supposed to be serious
whether it's hurt sneezing and literally
saying or her delivering her lines the
way she delivered yeah it was painful
which is sad because if the director was
there at the screening it's possible
that girls there too there's this scene
where this is really CGI evil dog is in
the closet his eyes are look they're
looking at the main dude and the dude
sits up and he's like what the hell is
that I like that's a shitty [ __ ]
script to read from that's what that is
they just break your heart when
carrie-anne moss shows up you're like oh
you're okay this is where we are now
well [ __ ] Trinity her character starts
making dumb ass calls too cuz like you
know people start dying because it's a
horror movie it's like you kid are the
prime suspects alright you can go this
is like the classic case of when this
kids trying to explain why he should
leave she should be like this kids out
of his [ __ ] mind I'm gonna book him
right now he is in handcuffs he is under
arrest but now you can she's like maybe
there's validity to this you're the
worst cop ever by the way I'm letting
you know that character that doesn't
exist the saving grace itself is the
premise I feel like this movie could
have a sequel that could be a reboot and
like I add first one never happened
here's the bye bye man like the ouija
movie had the first one with [ __ ] in the
second one I feel like bye-bye man could
have that treatment because the bye-bye
man premise is actually an interesting
premise that they managed to destroy
under the rubble of this wreck the
acting is horrible the script is
horrible the pacing is horrible when I'm
yawning praying for a jump cut in a
scary movie that's bad - bye bye man is
textbook January movie the bye-bye Man
is dog [ __ ] guys to the bye bye man have
don't that's gonna say have you seen it
what did you think about that implies
that you're going to please don't I'm
gonna ask you what is the worst horror
movie you have ever seen ever whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]